make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are picking up with uh
marvel zombies resurrection the one shot
like the story that kind of said hey
like marvel zombies is coming back it
came out like a year ago right so if i'm
being honest i think marvel may have
kind of missed the hype
i think marvel got wind of the fact that
dc was doing a zombie story and marvel
wanted to beat him to the punch but then
didn't really have a plan so nothing
ever came out after and then we got
deceased in the mid time which is like
an amazing story so i don't know like
i'm not really sure
what the grand plan is with this i mean
it's only four issues right so it's not
super lengthy uh but nonetheless in the
the resurrection one shot right it was
the idea that like galactus was kind of
out there in space just kind of seemed
to be floating or what have you but the
various superheroes or at least a series
of superheroes went out there to
investigate what was going on and some
pretty heavy hitters ended up traveling
out there for the purpose of like
understanding what was happening right
because they may need uh some pretty
heavy hitters especially when you're
dealing with galactus or something like
that we ended up basically finding out
that like the zombie infection was there
right and i don't believe
that we got an origin point which is to
say where it came from i believe it was
just there but regardless
all these various superheroes ended up
coming back to earth who were infected
and of course the whole zombie
apocalypse spread fast now we're not
given
a whole lot in terms of like how it was
that it's spread which kind of makes
sense in the original zombie story we
never got that the original zombie story
just
seemingly picked up in the middle of
everything and then just kind of went
forward from there
right but uh but nonetheless you know we
may end up getting some kind of
backstory either later on
in this series or possibly it's like a
companion series like a tie-in
that marvel might release somewhere
along the line but the overall gist is
that because peter parker had at one
point in time
been part of the uh of the the future
foundation which was kind of an offshoot
of the fantastic four and even part of
the fantastic four team itself
ultimately he was tasked by reed and
susan to keep an eye on valeria
and and franklin right to basically keep
an eye on them to make sure they stay
safe and it's kind of interesting that
franklin's here because he has such vast
reality warping powers i'm kind of
curious what role he's going to play
right because where peter is basically
rescuing them and and trying to get them
out of harm's way get them
as far away from the conflict as they
possibly can of course the vulture
swoops in the vulture you know takes out
a part of the
part of the the thing um and it's like
okay you know like not a great big huge
deal but then here comes johnny storm
and johnny storm because of the fact
that he's infected comes crashing into
the device and basically sends like the
entire ship crashing down right so it
has like valeria and everybody just like
fleeing for their life like you know
crying carrying on then peter parker
kind of falls
now that's where we sort of pick up with
what's going on in the moment right that
was kind of the outbreak moment right
that's that's all we really got and then
at the moment right now
we basically have uh we've got moonstone
here
i don't know why moonstone is here uh
but then you've also got franklin you've
got
you got franklin a little bit older you
got valeria and you've got forge now for
moonstone an important thing to
understand about her character is
it seems like she may or may not play a
more significant role later she had the
ability to like manipulate light
she had super strength super speed
different things like that she's by no
means a show stopper but
she is here because she's one of the
survivors and what seems to have been
going on here is that led by forge
uh they're just traveling from one
location to the next seemingly trying to
use for just uh forge's trek to
basically locate like a safe haven but
they've just kind of been on this
journey not too long after the the fall
of what seems to be new york and
probably the rest of the world to find
some measure of a safe haven the issue
with this is that along the way of
course we're kind of given this idea
that making noise different things like
that is not a good idea because it'll
attract what they call the
uh the respawn which is basically just
you know the undead and the result of
this is is this kind of like okay like
they end up you know killing a few of
them and that's basically it but the
really big moment that kind of comes out
of all this is that once those forces
are destroyed
you end up having the appearance of
nightcrawler and this is one of the
coolest things right because
nightcrawler is a character that's
painfully underrated
in marvel comics right in in a lot of
different ways
and i say that because i think that as
x-men fans
we know the worth of of nightcrawler but
it's one of these things
like when you see him unless you were
reading like the manifest destiny
nightcrawler story there weren't a whole
lot of instances where he was given like
any real do and so of course with him
teleporting around the other part of
this is
that forge is basically familiar with
with nightcrawler familiar enough
that he's able to take this guy on and
ultimately take him out but the other
thing that goes on here is he's
basically using the optic visor of
cyclops
now the visor's attached to a rig on his
back right so like obviously his
channeling energy from there i don't
really know why the cycle the the optic
beams of cyclops are necessary unless
you know
ford somehow found some kind of device
where it's using a kind of energy where
you know using the the beams of cyclops
or at least the visor cyclops seems to
be the most useful with nightcrawler
teleporting around they simply can't
keep up with them and so what we end up
doing is getting the appearance of
nana now nana is a character they had
kind of been talking about that valeria
had been mentioning a couple of times
and that she you know that franklin
takes very close to nana uh and and
really kind of views nana is like a
surrogate you know mother figure almost
or somebody there to take care of him
but nana was basically reprogrammed by
uh by valeria and the reason why is
because nana is just a great big huge
sentinel right it's just like literally
it looks like an omega sentinel like an
office a national emergency sentinel uh
but it was reprogrammed by valeria for
the purpose of protecting franklin now
one thing to understand this is kind of
a funny thing when it comes to marvel
size isn't everything just because
you're big
doesn't necessarily mean you're you're
really worth anything what it really
comes down to this is going in all the
wrong ways
what it really comes down to is the foe
you're facing off against and for all
the size the sentinels have
they're actually pretty easy to take out
like believe it or not like they're
pretty easy to destroy just a being of
sufficient power now we don't really
know what modifications have been made
to nana and that's really where things
kind of stand the test of what's going
on we don't really know what
modifications have been made and valeria
is probably the smartest person in the
world right now assuming that dr doom's
not alive we know that reid basically
was taken by the
by the zombies so like at least he was
one of the early ones to be infected uh
and so because that it's like okay i
wonder what is what is fully capable of
right because it's one thing one is when
it's machines
rebuilding themselves but machines are
still limited by what they understand at
that point in time
and valeria is much smarter than a
machine right she's the smartest person
in the world and even before reed and
and assuming doom died she was still one
of the smartest people in the world she
was she kind of switched the number one
spot with those three guys and so for
her to rebuild this in such a way it
seems pretty interesting but the other
part of this is that peter
takes personal offense to the idea of
forge actually leading them to the x-men
mansion because what he feels like is
they've kind of been manipulated now
this is sort of
the issue you run into with this right
this is one of the issues that you run
into with how zombies resurrection is
being done so far
because we get so little backstory
because we get so little
brick and mortar kind of filling things
in the reason and the motivations for
why characters feel the way they do is
kind of lost on us
we know peter parker was tasked with
keeping valeria and franklin safe
we know that nan is also there and that
peter parker will always keep an eye on
them we don't know how they ran into
moonstone we don't really know why it is
that he's pissed off about the fact that
that
forge brought them to the xavier mansion
outside of the fact that like you know
you've just been accidentally leading us
here to the xavier institute you know i
mean
there is a kind of explanation in so far
as like because of the fact that the
xavier institute housed
so many mutants that if we show up here
and these mutants are infected like
we're guaranteed to die
but at the end of the day peter has a
spider sense now the other thing going
on is because of spider sins is
happening all the time he's developing
like these headaches and forge's theory
is that if they go on long enough
they'll basically kill him
right so like they've got to finally
basically find a place to one keep peter
safe so his spider-sense can calm down
and two like basically a refuge of sorts
right forge's stance for being here
makes a lot more sense and
in the in the idea that the xavier
institute was a veritable fortress right
there's food and resources to last them
500 years
there's all kinds of technology there
more so than that he believes that they
can find some kind of a ship
to get them to the to the space arcs and
that's one of the first indications that
we get that humanity fled the planet
right then
in light of everything that was going on
humanity bailed because of that once
they finally make their way
into the house and they they basically
start poking around uh they find a few
things right the place looks
like it was kind of ransacked to a
degree there's the concern that any of
the resources that were there could be
taken but then they find all this crazy
writing on the wall and this writing
belongs to a group called the deadheads
right and the idea was that when the
outbreak happened
that there kind of arose a sort of cult
that saw the deadheads or
saw like the the respawns right like you
know beings who who were basically
reanimated as being like the next step
in evolution it is kind of crazy but one
of the important things this does tell
us is that no small measure of time had
passed
between when the outbreak originally
happened and when everything got to this
point right so while i wouldn't
necessarily go as far as to say it's
been something like five or ten years i
would go as far as to say
it's probably been a few years valeria
certainly looks older
franklin looks a little bit older right
so we'll say maybe something like four
years or so
again we're not given an exact time
frame here it's just you know and now
we're in this moment and things are
popping off but once they end up
approaching what looks like the pantry
they basically end up hearing a kind of
noise right they basically say like
we've got weapons you know like we'll
kill you if you
try to attack us they open the door and
it's a bunch of it looks like a bunch of
humans in there
right like a bunch of regular people and
this is really one of the things where
peter parker is interesting because of
course they end up basically you know
liberating them and setting them free
and when peter kind of starts to cry a
little bit forge's idea is that it's
like the old days right when they used
to save innocent people that kind of a
thing and peter's response is no that's
not why i'm crying i'm crying because
what awaits them out there is worse than
whatever it was that was coming for them
whatever it was that was here and my
first thought was to just do them in
right so like spare them trying to make
it out they won't last today right like
they'll end up being turned or worse
and like my thought was i should just
take them out and just make it easier
right peter parker was thinking about
just killing those people because it
would have been an easier
easier thing for them to deal with than
everything else out there and that's
wildly different for peter parker
right like that's that's wildly out of
character for peter it's not something
that he would do and that's designed to
really show us how bad
things have gotten like how far how far
things have fallen again
marvel kind of just running through
things really fast and i feel like if
i'm being honest with you guys i feel
like it really needs a little more umph
you know a little more
meat and potatoes to it you know you
know to kind of flush things out of it i
really feel like that's what this needs
but
of course this leads to the return of
the deadheads and one of the things that
that kind of goes on is they they
basically say that like those folks were
tributes like they were tributes that
were being fed to
basically the all strong this individual
there who was consuming those
individuals and with the deadheads
themselves they were considered to be
kind of
not really i guess there were assets to
a degree but so long as they were doing
what they were doing they would be
spared right they'd be allowed to kind
of continue existing and so it's it's
one part
obsession and an almost cult-like
mentality and the other part just
self-preservation
it's kind of what that seemed to be but
basically their whole thing is like the
all strong is going to come here now
like when he gets here
like there's no hope for any of you guys
you have no idea what it is that you've
done and ultimately you kind of started
hearing this sort of you know booming
sound and this kind of rumbling you know
and so on and and basically like this
guy kind of starts to pray to the
all-strong
and the all-strong ends up of course
biting him in half only for us to find
out this is beast right that hank mccoy
being infected while he was there or
else being infected and going there has
taken up residence in the xavier
institute now
initially there is an attempt to
rationalize with them right like forge
tries to rationalize with beasts and say
look like we can find a cure right like
we need you
like we need you hey mccoy like we know
you're still in there somewhere we need
your mind we need your intelligence you
know you're one of the foremost
geneticists right you understand the
nature of human biology if anybody can
fix this it would be you
and beast basically kind of utters the
word cure and then says like it's you
were curing and then kills forge and so
this really seems to take a page out of
the original zombies where they're still
very much cognizant they know exactly
who they are they're not really mindless
beasts right so it's different from
deceased in that sense in the way that
like the dc's characters who are out
there are just like attacking things
right like they almost kind of seem to
be completely mindless unless you're
being led by somebody like you know
like like adam or something like that
somebody who somehow managed to maintain
a higher level of thinking but that on
the whole
they're not really kind of what they
used to be right i mean in this one
they're still
pretty intelligent now with forge being
killed this leads to nana intervening
and nana basically goes to attack beast
and then of course beast ends up
attacking nana and of course this leads
into the arrival of
chewie now chewie had was was there and
it consumed some of the zombies they had
to dealt with along you know that they
had to deal with leading up to
basically the the showing up of
nightcrawler uh but chewie was a
character who appeared in giant-sized
captain marvel i think was giant-sized
cat maybe it was giant-sized miss marvel
number one during house of m
chewie is what's called a flirkin and
basically you see chewie in like the
marvel cinematic universe when it's the
cat that can eat anything but one thing
to understand
is the misconception there chewie
doesn't really like i mean it can
consume almost anything but it doesn't
really just let out tentacles the idea
is that flurkins contain with inside
their own bodies
basically like pocket dimensions like an
infinite amount of space inside of a
finite space as
crazy as that sounds but within that
space they can house any number of
things for chewie it's housing a mouth
that can consume
pretty much anything and that's
basically what happens here like chewy
ends up manifesting and then subduing
beasts like grabbing beasts bringing it
in killing him basically
like like doing beast in and that's it
right like peter parker kind of jumps in
and and you know basically you end up
having beast whose head is completely
severed from his body and then from
there it's like okay right like
moonstone more or less save the day to a
degree
alongside nana and then they start
asking beasts like what in the world is
going on here right like like franklin
approaches beast and says like where are
my parents where are my mom and dad
because these these zombies aren't
necessarily individual thinkers right
they share a singular hive mind
right like they they see what all the
others see and that's one of the things
that they warn is like because beast has
seen us now
it means that like wherever we are like
everybody else knows where we are and if
they knew that beast was in the xavier
institute then now they all know we're
in the xavier institute now this is
incredibly important
and the reason why is because if these
zombies are functioning with a higher
level of intelligence then this is
strategy
put each one of them in a particular
location to where heroes will most
likely
take refuge at and when they arrive
suddenly everybody else knows they're
there and if they're looking for
somebody in particular if they're
looking for franklin or they're looking
for valeria then they will know where
they are at
and that's exactly what's revealed here
they're hunting for franklin richards
one thing to understand is that
franklin's powers
don't seem to be working for some reason
we don't really know exactly why but
he's not really able to use his reality
working powers it was kind of an
offhanded remark that was made earlier
by valeria but the implication seems to
be he doesn't really have his high
levels of telepathy telekinesis matter
manipulation
or anything like that if he did he could
certainly use those and save the day but
also remember there's a big difference
between franklin as a little kid
and franklin as a full-on adult when
adult franklin richards showed up during
hickman's avengers and new avengers he
had
i'm sorry during his a fantastic four
run he had total control of his power
right he knew how to do
anything he wanted to do and he just
required the power of his younger self
in order to take on the other celestials
so that it was basically like two
franklins in one
but he still knew how to use his powers
one of the big problems that franklin's
always had as a little kid
is he never really knew how to use his
abilities he was never really trained on
how to use his powers by read there was
always something else going on or there
were mental blocks put in place
whatever the case was and so because of
that it made things a little complicated
for franklin's character but what beast
basically says here is like your family
is with the galactus hive now no one's
seen the galactus hive for quite some
time and so either they've taken it
somewhere
it's hidden but nobody knows where it's
at and then basically b says like
they're hunting for you franklin like we
are looking for you and we are going to
find you
like come and see your mother and father
right like come back to manhattan and
we'll find out what's going on and so
at that point you end up having you know
moonstone who basically destroys
the head of beast and then she takes off
now the reason she takes off is because
of the fact that in her mind
going on a suicide mission to the
galactus hive is kind of stupid right
like the whole reason she joined peter
parker in the first place
is that she was attracted to the kind of
fatherly role that peter was playing for
franklin and valerie right she liked
that but more so than that they seem to
have a purpose right and one of the
things she talks about is like in the
early days
of the invasion of new york you had
bucky barnes you had a few people here
and there who were fighting off against
the invasion right so again
a good amount of time seems to have
passed here but they had a role to play
right it was good guys versus bad guys
things were pretty straightforward but
peter parker isn't really much of a hero
anymore he's lost in in almost every
conceivable way
the way that uh the way that moonstone
sees it and then in turn going on a
suicide mission
to the galactus hive seems even worse
and so she's like you guys go do your
thing but i am not going with you right
like i'm not going
on some suicide mission to the galactus
hive in an effort to find the parents
the the
you know zombie appearance of some kid
so he can have some hope that's not
going to work but the other perspective
from like valeria and franklin is
far less grim right in their mind
valeria even asked the question what
makes us think they're not some kind of
evolutionary next step
right like what keeps us from thinking
that what keeps it from being true it is
entirely possible
and reid always said like there would be
a way like there's always a way
we're talking about a biological
organism there has to be a cure for this
and so it's really hope against hope
with valeria and franklin believing they
can find reed and they can actually
bring things back to normal now the way
in which they're able to find the
galactus hive comes from valeria and
it's actually pretty genius
because of the fact that beast was on
the original mission that essentially
discovered this radiation where they
were infected and they began to end up
becoming zombies that because that
radiation is still prevalent and beast
they can actually track its source and
they can get back to the galactus hive
now peter jumps in the way and says this
is ridiculous right like you cannot cure
a dead organism it doesn't work this way
it's not how that kind of stuff works
and it's kind of the hope of franklin
and valeria how do you know they're dead
how do you know that they are actually
dead like there's no real way to know
there i mean
maybe they are maybe they're not but
like we can go there we can we can
tend to them and we can find out and so
of course when you end up having them
more or less kind of camping for a bit
peter parker getting some rest and then
waking up only to find that like valeria
and franklin and them are gone he goes
on the hunt for them only to be attacked
out of nowhere and for us to find out
that moonstone has become infected and
where she goes to attack peter parker
suddenly she starts getting chopped into
pieces peter also finds franklin and
valeria right so
they're still safe but like she starts
getting chopped into little pieces
and when that happens then suddenly we
get this kind of question coming out of
nowhere right like let me see and then
we find out that it's blade
before this one showed up i overheard
you know the other two saying you guys
are gonna go find the galactus hive do
you have room for one more right so now
they're here with blade and believe it
or not that makes a difference right
blade being here the day is in a lot of
ways
saved but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you